Für alle Erstfliegern erkläre ich euch jetzt einmal das Kurvenflieden am Anfang.
Liegen wir heraus, wichtig sind wir nach dem Start erst einmal die Richtung behalten gerade rauskommen.
Gerade weg vom Handfliegen ist für uns erst einmal das Wichtigste.
Und sobald wir weg vom Hand sind, können wir probieren ins kurze Kreizbruch,
können wir anziehen, um mit dem Friedle wackeln, wenn das nicht reicht,
dann müssen wir uns hier nach hinten in das Kurze greifen, sodass man so möglich ist,
möglich so drinnen setzen wir das jetzt bei jeder Fall.
Dann bei jeder Kurve immer zuerst Blickrichtung Luftraum, kann ich auf die Seite drehen.
Ist da frei, nicht dass ich da eine Kurve einleite und direkt dem Handrenden in die Kappereinpflege.
Da sie meinen treiten, also Schaul, Luftraum frei und bevor wir jetzt mit der Rämser arbeiten,
immer
zuerst Gewicht auf diese Seite legen.
Und ihr seht, mit Sitzbrett geht das sehr gut, wer die Beine freiheit, der kann das linke Beine
über das Rechte drüber leben und kriegt so noch mehr Körperverlagerung nehmen.
Und erst dann nehmen wir unterstützen die Kremse mit dazu.
Langsam mit der Bremse arbeiten, wenn er merkt, okay, das dürft noch ein bisschen mehr.
Oder ich sage das halt, hier nur noch mal 3 cm dürfte noch mal 3 cm ziehen.
Ausleitung ist immer leutere mit dem kurze Kind setzen.
Und ich sage euch ja eigentlich alles an, das heißt, jetzt startet immer normalerweise
durchgebremst.
Blick auf die Kurvenseite, Gewicht und dann kommt die eigene Bremse noch mehr.
Die andere geht vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen nach oben, das sage ich euch alles an.
Und ausleiten, du meinst immer zuerst das Gewicht über neue Treiblingen und dann die
Außenseite bremsen, was man immer herausgebremst, aus jeglichen Kurven oder dynamischen
Aufbauten herauskommt.